mosination we've been here doing the
boring work just cracked 400 episodes on
the game podcast we have been putting a
ton of effort into the podcast and it's
been showing from the amount you guys
been sharing it and commenting on it and
posting on it and it's really been
unbelievable um I don't deserve you guys
and so thank you again but we also now
are on all the platforms so this is new
Spotify we're on iTunes and we're on the
other 16 platforms that less than two
percent of you guys listen on but if
it's one of the weird ones we're on
there too and you can find it by just
searching my last name for Mosey or the
game or both of those words put together
if you work out or you're on the road or
you're doing the dishes you're cleaning
the house whatever it is it makes that
time net time so you can make it
cleaning University mobile University
workout University so that we are
getting better in more than one way at
the same time and that's like the best
thing you can possibly do in life and so
if you haven't checked out the podcast
check it out lots of emoji Nation I'll
see you on the pod